dimanche
10 mois j'ai chopé la grippe dont je
peux dire que toute ma vie j'ai jamais
autant fait la bise aux gens
ah ouais je vois je suis un peu déçu
d'habitude j'ai un herpès en même temps
et
samassa m'a bloqué bon on est généreux
on n'est pas enfin bon quoi de neuf
plein de trucs extraordinaires cette
semaine l'éducation nationale alors
selon le classement de la pizza en
termes de scolarité on est nul on est
vraiment bon si la france recule c'est
par humilité on veut pas humilier par
notre niveau scolaire les pays dont on
va finir par rejoindre le niveau de vie
on est
le problème en fait c'est le niveau des
profs on a trouvé un prof qui a une
moyenne de 4 sur 20 à ses examens de
profs
pour peu que le mec a eu 18 ans travaux
manuels et 16 ans flûte à bec
tu as une petite idée de ses notes en
maths quoi tu dis enfin le principe de
l'école c'est que c'est le prof qui
apprend aux gosses pas l'un vers enfin
avec une moyenne pareil tu m'étonnes que
les profs font plusieurs fois la même
année c'est pas par choix c'est juste
pour finir par comprendre ce qu'ils
enseignent
[Applaudissements]
la bonne nouvelle c'est que paraît qu'on
a un système très performant pour les
élites or c'est un système qui a adapté
aux gens très voilà c'est vrai que quand
on voit les élites françaises qu est ce
qu elle lui met à la mondialisation
tu vois si mercedes s'appelle google
n'investissent pas en france c'est juste
par complexe d'infériorité
théâtre subventionné après olivier py
patrice chéreau la france découvre le
génie scénique de jean luc mélenchon
impressionnant de maturité tu lui donnes
un trottoir cas de figure en effet ben
hur
vie nocturne après david cathy guetta et
régine le ps s'est mis à organiser des
soirées à thème génial c'est le concept
c'est la soirée lieux communs tu vois tu
trouves une évidence tout le monde doit
être pur et boum dj et là c'était la
soirée contes la haine alors il prévoit
aussi une soirée un plus un égale de la
night de la pluie qui mouille ça va être
alors c'est vraiment les seuls soirée où
j'arrive à me trouvais génial parce que
tu déblatère une banalité les gens
disent pas [ __ ] alors j'ai abordé une
fille je lui dis franchement la une deux
minutes c'est nauséabond m'a dit voir
marine le pen y trouve pas que c'est une
fachos
c'est des trucs je commence lundi est là
et c'est [ __ ] enfin je te regarde
dans les yeux et je viens de me faire
traverser par un sentiment étrange mais
se trouve pas que la paix ça fait moins
de morts que la guerre
et attentats temps tu m'inspires un truc
au fond j'ai l'impression que tous les
hommes naissent libres et égaux en droit
par la fis scotché m'a dit toi tu as dû
faire normale sup et où vous écoute on
s'en fout des études ce qui compte c'est
le coeur là il m'a dit on va chez toi ou
chez moi je dis non c'est gentil mais je
me remettrai à faire l'amour que
lorsqu'on aura éradiquer la faim dans le
monde en revanche le pipe aux toilettes
cette polémique le psg a commencé son
match contre lyon sans un seul joueur
français
excusé d'avoir envie de gagner
sondage alors on sent que c'est on sent
que c'est l'hiver on parle déjà de la
bouffe qui colle à l'estomac ceci fait
froid les frimas leurs rentes sirach la
prostate de hollande
moi je suis inquiet hollande où il en
est et essayer de faire du buzz avec un
abat il aurait pu trouver un morceau
noble quoi
j'ai mal aux abdos
une opération de prostate qui a soulevé
beaucoup de questions c'est un phénomène
il paraît que c'est la première prostate
qui arrive à fonctionner sans testicules
[Musique]
on l'a retrouvé dans une crèche dans une
position peu après le président des
bisous le président des nounous c'est
vrai cette photo vraiment elle a fait
mal mais elle s'adresse aux français a
dit vous voyez moi aussi j'ai les mains
dans la merde
mais je comprends pourquoi il a un peu
du coup c'est pas le surpoids c les
oreillons parce qu'à force vers les
crèches
internationale en afghanistan après 12
ans de guerre ça progresse ils vont
rétablir la lapidation pour adultère
c'est normal c'est normal dans un pays
où il n'y a rien c'est quand même super
indécent d'avoir une vie sexuelle
pimentée
dans la foulée ils ont aussi sorti un
rapport qui estime que les cultures de
substitution l'opium ont échoué
non mais sans la c'est vrai que c'est
super courant le dealer qui vient de
voir emboiter qui ai dit écoute j'ai pas
de coke en revanche des salsifis et des
rattes du touquet
elles viennent d'un producteur
et demain je reçois des pêches du
roussillon ça va vraiment faire des
dégâts
ukraine les manifestants veulent que
l'ukraine intègre l'europe ça leur
suffit pas de perdre à l'uefa allure
vision ils veulent en plus se faire
humilier à la bce
alors évidemment l'ukraine fait du bruit
et les femen réagissent les gens uriner
sur la photo du président ukrainien
c'est bizarre allez les happenings des
feymen ce quelque chose ça devient un
mix entre la fiac michaël youn et une
visite médicale
sexes
en matière de passé sexuel les hommes
déplore les occasions manquées et les
femmes les expériences décevantes c'est
tellement vrai je me souviendrai
toujours ce moment où elle a claqué la
porte quand j'ai fait rentrer lane dans
la chambre
j'ai compris art le chanteur m a fait
une prestation dans le métro à paris
alors je veux pas juger mais je trouve
que c'est pas la manière la plus futée
de se faire du fric aux blacks
pour le côté positif cela va peut-être
donner des idées aux [ __ ] ce serait
une bonne idée les [ __ ] dans le
métro surtout sur les rails
non mais pas vous pas vous peut pas vous
faire non vous êtes un peu à part dans
les [ __ ] vous êtes le seul qui
arrivait à vivre de votre métier
bonne nouvelle alors ouais ce soir il ya
deux grosses soirées miss france ou
téléthon c'est pas par machisme je
préfére miss france c'est quand même
plus facile de s'attacher à des
personnes dont on est à peu près sûr
qu'elles passeront l'hiver et qui pour
les plus talentueuses finiront peut-être
dans un porno
alors pas belle la vie et pour être sûr
de ne rien rater de l'inaptitude abonnez
vous il m'était impossible eux